Democrats be careful what you wish for
former Obama adviser David Axelrod
getting mocked over a clueless tweet
that laments held some far-right
candidates won after a key primary last
night saying quote another far-right
election denier wins this time in New
Hampshire feels like the Republicans are
doing everything possible to Foster
frustrate their chances of regaining
control of the Senate but maybe David
should check with his fellow Democrats
because they've been spending millions
in campaign ads to boost those Mega
Republican candidates and bury the
moderates so much for that threat to
democracy and Elizabeth Warren basically
couldn't answer when called out on it
I think this is just an extraordinarily
dangerous
I am so deeply Disturbed that there are
still so many mega Republicans so why
are Democrats supporting and pouring
money into their campaigns I I believe
that these folks are very very dangerous
she said all right Greg uh you know what
they're spending something like 53
million dollars the Democrats on these
Mega candidates pushing out the more
moderate Republicans and then
criticizing them and saying they're a
threat to democracy but like raising
them on a pedestal what's going on I'm
beginning to think they really don't
mean what they're saying gee I don't
know but I mean like trying to I think
trying to win an election is more
important than avoiding the greatest
existential threat since the Civil War
tells me maybe they might have been
exaggerating and they also shows how
little faith they have in their
candidates that they would shift their
energies to the other candidates rather
than try to like figure out who their
best person is the other thing is as I
shuffle from my notes I am curious why
is this election meddling somehow less
worse than the Russians spending what
was it 100 Grand on Facebook ads was
that what it was that ended up doing
nothing I mean is there is there some
principle here like so it's okay okay if
we meddle but somebody else can't buy
ads this is ten times a hundred times a
thousand times this is an existential
threat yes to our election system and it
exposes their extreme Maga grift this is
why we need the media an actual
objective media because if they were so
terrified of these monsters right why
are they trying to help them win a media
would actually go crazy on this story
imagine if we I'm going to say we as a
republican even though I'm a registered
independent or I think I am I don't know
I forgot what if we decided that we
would amplify the Socialists in the
Democratic party you do
support any socialists but you imagine
if we did that the media would go crazy
if they found out like Fox was sending
money to support socialists anyway but
we don't do that because we're better
people okay Jesse isn't this about the
Democrats having nothing to talk about
and instead they're trying to make
Donald Trump the centerpiece and the
person that they can focus everyone on
so that they don't have to talk about
what a mess our economy is explained it
perfectly I don't have to add anything
to that and and Greg is right we are
better people but we lose yeah
but we lose With Honor we should take
notes and maybe start funneling money to
the squad types and the Dem primaries so
we can knock them off easier in the
general Greg also said something very
smart yesterday and it's so rare it
stuck out I remembered it he said it
seems like the Democrats want it more
because they'll do anything to stay in
power so I'm not even worried about this
what they're doing here with these
primaries this is small ball look what
they did in the last election they
pushed the Pfizer deal back after the
election to hurt Trump people probably
died because of that they brought the
CIA into the last election to lie in
that letter about the laptop they blew
up all the election laws you know got
rid of voter ID pushed out the signature
requirements look at another election I
mean they covered up Benghazi a terror
attack so they could win they turn the
IRS against the Tea Party what was the
last time I think Joe Biden said
Republicans want to make black slaves
again and now he's calling us all
fascists they just didn't he just raid
the treasury to bribe as voters before a
midterm I mean this guy raids they lie
they they illegally leak come on Judge I
mean this is the least of my at least
what they're doing here is legal yeah
I'm not worried about their hypocrisy
I'm worried about their skullduggery now
there's a word all right Dana I'm
fascinated by this guy Don Bolduc who
won over okay he's a he's a Trumper
apparently or certainly a right-winger
that the Democrats apparently supported
but he won over Mitch McConnell's
candidate and so the question is you
know as we see this across the country I
mean who's going to win in these races
well it's if this is really interesting
so the race was very close it was like
36.8 to 36.1 so the Democrats effort
helped him get over the Finish Line okay
yeah now he was outspent by a lot
he only had like seventy thousand
dollars in his account or something but
my words he could still win Maggie
Hassan's record and the Senate is
horrendous she has no legislative Record
She votes with Chuck Schumer 100 of the
time and immediately what did they do
today as soon as balduck as soon as
Chuck Morse conceded and general balduck
is now going to be the candidate the
first thing they did was say he's so
extreme oh my gosh what will happen to
the world now if the Democratic National
Committee is not worried about Baltic
being one election night away from the
Senate why should voters and the other
thing I would point out is that could be
a concern is
uh that abortion is like a 70 30 issue
in that state that was the first ad that
they ran what they said is that he's
extreme on abortion so baltic's already
commented on that but I would point out
this he started as a private in the Army
worked his way up to be a general rode
horseback across Afghanistan his voters
in New Hampshire would walk across coals
for him he held 50 Town Halls he was out
there and about it's a small state it's
an independent state and I think that
the Democrats they are probably going to
get what they asked for which is Baltic
in the Senate yeah that that's
interesting and you know Jessica the
majority of Americans who listened to
Biden's speech where it was the
anti-magus speech
um they found it 60 percent they found
it to be divisive that along with this
kind of perplexing they're promoting the
right-wing Maga that the anti-democratic
candidates you know people have to
wonder in the Democrat Party what what
they really are doing
well we certainly know what Joe Biden
was doing and he was clarifying that
there's a subset of the Republican party
and it's just a piece of it it's
certainly not the totality that doesn't
believe in the institutions that we
believe in that doesn't adhere to
democratic Norms that doesn't accept
reality what institutions that we
believe in like elections like voting
and then certifying elections I mean he
was talking about people that wanted to
hang Mike Pence for not doing the
president's bidding and overturning the
election so that's what Joe Biden was
talking about you can't have an opinion
on an election that you can't be a
skeptic or else you're a terrorist yeah
and then the whole I'm sorry is that
I began with and I returned to he was
talking about a small subset of
Republicans and he's for a week been
reminding you that he clarified that and
he continues to clarify it he works with
Republicans he got gun control done and
infrastructure done with Republicans he
made good on those promises that he can
work with Republicans who believe in the
same kinds of things that we do which
includes election Integrity to the point
about supporting these candidates I've
not been in favor of it if even one of
these people wins their election it
obviously invalidates the entire
strategy and it's incredibly scary
because one of these elections could be
a Kerry Lake it could be Doug masteriano
she is going to win I agree she's great
she's great yeah no I mean you say that
sarcastically but you have no evidence
on why she isn't I think she's
incredibly persuasive
Kerry Lake we're talking about the same
person right running foreign
I do think people who
don't function in the same reality that
the rest of us do where Joe Biden is
legitimate President
Clinton did that for four years exactly
did she continued to complain
and the Russians were involved but in
any events liberal cities a startling
number of residents are now victims I
wouldn't Brian kill Mead I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now